[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
members of the jury have you arrived at
a verdict a verdict is reached as we
wind down day four of deliberations in
the trial for ex-cop kim potter plus
another case on verdict watch won't see
any movement as the jury in the gelane
maxwell federal trial takes a holiday
break then later could dna be the answer
to figuring out who killed jonbenet
ramsey police say new technology might
help close the case long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome on the prime daily everybody
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
alongside terry austin a decision is in
from the jury after roughly 27 and a
half hours of deliberations ex-cop kim
potter was found guilty of all counts
the former brooklyn center minnesota
police officer shot and killed an
unarmed motorist during a traffic stop
earlier this year she faced first and
second degree manslaughter charges judge
regina chu read the verdict in open
court on thursday afternoon
in the matter of state of minnesota
versus kimberly potter
court file number 27cr21
7490
we the jury on the charge of
manslaughter in the first degree while
committing a misdemeanor
on or about
april 11 2021
in hennepin county state of minnesota
find the defendant guilty
the verdict on count two is we the jury
on the charge of manslaughter in the
second degree
culpable negligence on or about
april 11 2021
in hennepin county state of minnesota
find the defendant guilty
now here are the details of the case on
april 11th potter and an officer in
training pulled over dante wright for an
expired tag after determining he had a
warrant for a weapons charge they
attempted to take right into custody now
body camera footage shows the struggle
between officers and right potter said
she accidentally pulled her firearm
instead of her taser when she shot right
in the chest wright's car then sped away
crashed into another car and he died
from his injuries after the verdict was
read potter was taken into custody
without bail and her sentencing is set
for february all right so let's break
this down i'm here with terry austin as
well as trial attorney bernardo
villalone it's great to have you both
here terry i have to start what do you
think it was that just tipped this jury
over into
convicting potter across the board
there were a number of factors that
tipped that jury over first of all
she should have recognized the
difference between a taser and a gun
they're different colors they weigh
differently they're on different sides
of your body and we know that the jury
asked to see those weapons so that
definitely was a tipping factor second
of all she had 26 years of experience
she was trained on a regular basis and i
think the jury said she should have
known better she should have
de-escalated that situation and finally
jesse i really do think that the jury
recognized if
you can be held criminally responsible
for a mistake because it's either
negligence or it was recklessness and in
this case that jury decided it was both
but bernardo you know what's surprising
i mean were you surprised that they
found her guilty of both charges a lot
of people were predicting maybe a split
verdict given the different language of
the charges and maybe you know the
severity of first degree first second
degree
well the jury has spoken and obviously
they were able to get over the hump in
terms of the recklessness manslaughter
in the first degree because they found
kim potter guilty of both i will say
this the hangup was that first count of
manslaughter in the first degree because
if you recall they got the case on
monday by tuesday they sent out a note
that possibly they were hung however
when the verdict was read today what
judge chu said is in regards to
manslaughter in the first degree that
verdict came yesterday however math law
in the second degree the jury had that
verdict on tuesday at 10 30 in the
morning so they also was stuck after
recklessness but they got it
yeah and it's curious to see if they
were kind of stuck up on how severe that
first degree charge was there's more to
talk about with kim potter and we're
going to get into it and get into it
later on in the program but i want to
share this now because this week a
michigan appeals court vacated the
conviction of a former michigan state
gymnastics coach nearly two years after
she was found guilty for lying during
the larry nassar investigation on
tuesday the court determined that the
2018 interviews with kathy clagis were
quote inconsequential
to the nassar investigation though a
judge did not rule on whether claygus
was telling the truth during those
interviews in february 2020 collegus was
found guilty on two counts of lying to a
police officer two gymnasts testified
that they told klages about nassar's
abuse in 1997 when they were just 14 and
16 years old claygus maintained she does
not remember the 1997 conversations
from here the case would go to the
michigan supreme court if the state's
attorney general's office wishes to
appeal over now to an update on a story
we first broke to you earlier this week
a colorado district attorney is asking
the court to reconsider a 110 year
sentence for a truck driver who caused a
deadly crash the same prosecutor's
office that secured a conviction is now
asking that 26-year-old rahel aguilera
medeiros receive a reduced sentence this
comes after the 110-year sentence
sparked widespread criticism as many say
the crash was unintentional in 2019
aguilera medeiros lost control of his 18
wheeler on the highway he came upon stop
traffic because of another crash and
instead of taking a ramp he drove on the
shoulder before causing a 28-car pileup
as a result of this four people died and
several others were hurt aguilera
medeiros was found guilty of 27 counts
including vehicular homicide in october
now reconsidering the sentence will not
affect the conviction it's only going to
give the court more flexibility a status
hearing is set for monday morning still
ahead on long crime daily we're going to
take a look at the federal sex crimes
trial of elaine maxwell and what's to
come as the jury weighs the evidence
that decides the fate of the british
socialite but first kim potter found
guilty on first and second degree
manslaughter charges what does that mean
as the case moves on to her sentencing
we're gonna break that down next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
and welcome back to long prime daily
everybody we're continuing our
discussion about the kim pyre trial out
in minnesota after the jury found the
ex-cop guilty of first and second-degree
manslaughter potter shot and killed
dante wright at a traffic stop earlier
this year with her claiming that she
mistook her firearm for her taser but
now the question is what will the
punishment be and what will her
sentencing look like when it's set for
february under minnesota law potter
would only be sentenced on the top
charge while first degree manslaughter
carries a maximum sentence of 15 years
behind bars potter having no previous
criminal history will most likely face a
presumptive lower range of imprisonment
and will only serve two-thirds of a
sentence however the prosecution is
going to be seeking a higher sentence
and they might cite certain factors in
support of that ultimately the
sentencing will be up to judge regina
chu so terry based on all of these
factors what do you think a sentence for
kim potter could look like and i mean do
you think she's going to get something
just like just probation because that's
what her defense team wants
no way they're overreaching there she
actually resulted in the death of
someone so there won't be probation here
and your analysis was perfect jesse the
fact that they're going with that higher
account of manslaughter 1 to 15 then
they're going to apply the sentencing
guidelines and that's going to take it
down the average is about seven years
and then with good behavior and we
expect that she will have good behavior
she's going to probably serve about
two-thirds of that which comes down in
my opinion to about four and a half
years so i think all in all she's going
to serve time there's no way she's going
to get just probation i think that's a
greedy ask
so this could change though bernardo
based on what the prosecution presents
during a sentencing like aggravating
factors these kind of blakely factors
what kind of aggravation aggravating
factors would work here for the
prosecution in this case
so what the prosecution is going to
argue to judge you that kim potter
abused her position of power she abused
her authority in the sense that she was
a police officer when she caused the
death of dante wright so i think that is
the most powerful point that they can
argue i don't know if they'll be
successful however we'll see because we
know from derek chaven's trial that we
did find that judge did find that he
violated his abuse of power
yeah i'm curious to see what that's
going to look like and also whether kim
potter is going to make a statement
during her sentencing so we'll continue
to follow this case because there's
still a lot of play there now want to
switch gears because a former olympic
athlete is facing finance related
crimes such as money laundering and
making false statements to a bank all
about allegedly lying on loan
applications to get millions of dollars
in coronavirus related relief payments
so this all stems with speed skater
allison marie baver who won the bronze
medal as part of team usa in 2020 in
2010 i should say in vancouver after
retiring from skating seven years later
she started a film and tv production
company allison baver entertainment
now prosecutors say that baver submitted
eight separate paycheck protection
program or ppp loan applications last
april to help her company she claimed
that nearly five million dollars and she
claimed a nearly five million dollars
average monthly payroll but court
documents show that in reality she had
no payroll at all favor also said that
she employed hundreds of people but
prosecutors say that was also a lie the
application led to baber illegally
receiving 10 million dollars in
coronavirus relief loans federal
officials want the former skater to
forfeit 9.7 million dollars of the funds
if convicted baver faces up to 40 years
behind bars she's set to be arraigned in
federal court january 18th and has not
yet entered a plea for the charges and
the parents of a teenager charged with
shooting and killing four of his
classmates in november at a michigan
high school are requesting a lower bond
james and jennifer crumbly face
involuntary manslaughter charges after
being accused of allowing their son
ethan to access the gun he allegedly
used in the shooting and a failing to
pull him from school when they were told
about a concerning drawing namely
depicting a gun and a person who appears
to have been shot the pair were believed
to have fled before their arrest in
early december the crumblies have been
jailed on a five hundred thousand dollar
bond since then their defense attorney
asked wednesday that it be lowered to
one hundred thousand dollars she said
they could even be electronically
monitored if released in the court
filing the crumbly said that the gun
which was allegedly used was locked up
and that they didn't know their son was
any danger to other students that
request is expected to be considered at
a hearing january 7th and coming up on
long crime daily the jury takes a
holiday break as we await a verdict in
the federal sex crimes trial of delane
maxwell plus could a 25 year old cold
case be solved using dna the latest from
investigators on the jonbenet ramsey
murder
[Music]
and welcome back everybody let's head
over to new york as the jury adjourns
for a holiday break in the sex crimes
trial for british socialite galen
maxwell now i should tell you so far the
jury has deliberated for about 16 hours
maxwell the former girlfriend of jeffrey
epstein pleaded not guilty to six felony
sex crimes charges over the last few
weeks the jury heard testimony from
women who say maxwell quote groomed them
for epstein to sexually abuse epstein
was charged with similar crimes in 2019
but as you may recall he was found dead
by suicide before his case went to trial
the prosecution's case focused on
maxwell's connection to epstein
meanwhile the defense told jurors that
maxwell is simply a scapegoat for the
former financier during deliberations
the jury is asked for transcripts of
testimony from maxwell's four accusers
they also requested notes from an fbi
interview with one of the accusers from
2007 which hasn't given much indication
on whether they're close to a decision
or not i should tell you that long
crimes own adam classfeld has been
following this case closely has actually
been in that courthouse and we caught up
with him to learn what the latest is in
the jury deliberations
they have the day off today uh they were
invited by judge nathan to
convene today if they chose to they but
they turned down that invitation their
exact words in fact and their jury note
was no thank you so that was a
quick end to the first week of
deliberations we only had two full days
of deliberations uh adding up to some 16
hours of deliberations so they have been
keeping busy during that short time
frame they have been requesting the
transcripts of multiple alleged victims
and as it turns out as of right before
the closing of deliberations yesterday
they requested all four accusing
witnesses they got the fourth that was
uh kate the woman testifying under that
pseudonym
and they had previously requested the
transcripts of the testimony of annie
farmer
jane and carolyn
and so with that the jury will reconvene
on monday bernardo let me start with you
any concern here with the jury taking
this break in the middle of
deliberations and then coming back to
finish the case
i'm not concerned just because it's a
holiday so you got to think with the
holidays people aren't really focused as
to deliberating because look for example
the ken potter jury they're sequestered
and they came back with a verdict
because they know it's christmas same
thing when we did the uh there was
another case that it was doing
thanksgiving the mod aubry case and they
came back right the day before
thanksgiving so in terms of this jury
they heard so much testimony and there's
so much that they need to think about
that they themselves were the ones that
requested no we do not want to come in
to continue deliberating that we request
to come in on monday instead
getting into the substance of terry and
these jury questions with the jury
taking such a close look at the
accuser's testimony if you were the
prosecution would you be nervous right
now
i would be nervous if i were the
prosecution actually i think both
parties should be nervous we understand
that after one of the questions asking
about the testimony from reports the
defense attorneys were giving each other
high fives i think that's too early to
celebrate you never know how this is
going to go they're looking at the
detailed testimonies of annie farmer
carol and jane and kate all four of
those accusers and there were some
inconsistencies carolyn as we mentioned
basically there was an inconsistency in
a 2007 interview with the fbi there were
also inconsistencies with jane in her
interviews in 2019 and 2020 so i think
the jury is taking a careful look and
they're going to determine whether or
not their testimony was credible and i
think it could go either way at this
point and neither party should be
celebrating while these jurors are
asking questions
all right maybe it's still early to
predict what will happen galen maxwell
but the jury will get some rest then
they'll continue their deliberations and
we'll follow what happens next
when we come back investigators are
hoping that newer technology will bring
new
new answers to a case that has gone cold
for quite some time coming up next the
announcement on what could help solve a
25 year old case i'm talking of course
about the murder of jonbenet ramsey
we'll be back
[Music]
and welcome back to long crime daily
everybody nearing the 25th anniversary
of the murder of jonbenet ramsey the
boulder colorado police department has
announced that it may still use dna
technology to help solve this cold case
the six-year-old's murder shocked the
nation back in 1996 when her body was
found in the basement of her family home
just one day after christmas ramsay's
parents reported her missing saying that
a ransom note had been left behind she
was later found bludgeoned and strangled
ramsey's family was ruled out as
suspects and no one was ever charged in
the case in a statement boulder police
said it has reviewed more than 1500
pieces of evidence related to the case
and followed up with more than 21 000
tips the department says it quote
continues to use new technology to
enhance the investigation now that it
regularly checks dna evidence for new
matches now bernardo we are no strangers
to dna solving cold cases but these this
kind of dna it has its advantages and it
has its disadvantages walk us through it
so in regards to this specific type of
dna that they're trying to look into
it's more of now they want to look into
genetic dna in terms of to see if they
can find someone where there's a
familiar match and once they find
someone within the familiar match then
they can start looking deeper into what
are the connections within the family
what is the family tree to see whether
there will be a positive hit as to that
dna i'll tell you this dna has been
known to crack cases open i remember the
first homicide that i tried as a
homicide prosecutor at the brooklyn da's
office it was a cold case from 20 years
prior where dna did not exist and it was
dna that cracked the case in terms of
that the person had the deceased had the
dna skin cells of the perpetrator
underneath her nails and it was the
coming of dna that helped open up that
case and solve it
terry you know what i find odd though is
that they kind of made a similar
announcement of this back in 2016. why
are they announcing this now this dna
technology when they haven't even
identified a suspect it feels like
something's happening behind the scenes
i agree i think what they are doing here
the authorities want the public to know
that they're doing something here and
that they didn't drop the ball remember
this was such a huge case back at the
time it was all over the news and the
authorities were focusing on the parents
and the parents claimed then that they
were focusing on the wrong people that
they weren't following credible leads
and so because of that this is part of
the reason why the case went cold this
is part of the reason why they weren't
able to solve the case so i think the
authorities are trying to say look we
are following this up we want you to
know we have not dropped the ball and
it's a message to the parents it's a
message to the community that they are
continuing to follow up on this dna even
though they don't have a suspect and the
other reason jesse is when they make
these types of announcements they always
give a telephone number to contact they
always say what they are doing because
they want the public to contact them and
tell them about more leads if possible
so it does help them to solve the case
to continuously keep it in the public
eye even though it's 25 years old yeah
it is such an eerie case and still gives
people shivers so if they can find
answers that would be incredible
bernarda terry thank you so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you